ah
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález unas
declaraciones del presidente de estados
unidos joe biden tienen nervioso al
mundo entero por las repercusiones que
puede tener en el desarrollo de la
invasión de rusia a ucrania o la guerra
en ucrania tal ha sido la magnitud de
estas declaraciones que la casa blanca
ha tenido que matizar las ha tenido que
matizar esas palabras del presidente
vaivén que dijo que en rusia debería de
haber un cambio de régimen escuchemos
catch safe por dios este hombre no puede
seguir en el poder
ni piensa en avanzar un centímetro sobre
territorio de la otan
tenemos obligaciones sagradas tenemos la
sagrada obligación según el artículo
quinto de defender cada centímetro del
territorio de la otan
esas palabras esas declaraciones de
biden en varsovia generaron por supuesto
reacciones en el kremlin desde la sede
del gobierno ruso dijeron que el
presidente de byd en a él no le
corresponde decidir si vladimir putin
permanece en el poder o no porque el
presidente de rusia es elegido por los
ciudadanos rusos la pregunta que queda
sobre la mesa es cómo va a reaccionar
moscú a estas declaraciones aparte de
esto vuelve a quedar también sobre la
mesa la posibilidad de establecer el
estatus de neutralidad como garantía de
seguridad para ucrania sobre este tema
se pronunció precisamente el presidente
del clan de ucrania volodymyr selenski
grandes garantías de seguridad y
neutralidad el estatus no nuclear de
nuestro estado estamos listos para ello
este es el punto más importante fue el
punto principal para la federación rusa
sí recuerdo correctamente del por qué
ellos iniciaron esta guerra
rusia y ucrania comenzarán una nueva
mesa de diálogo esta vez en estambul en
la metrópolis turca en una nueva mesa de
conversaciones auspiciadas precisamente
por el gobierno turco ankara se ha
ofrecido varias veces para ayudar en un
diálogo entre estas partes pero eso sí
ha rechazado a nivel internacional la
anexión de la península de crimea al
territorio ruso turquía es miembro de la
otan pero también es un país muy cercano
a rusia y puede jugar un papel
importante en esta mesa de diálogo el
mundo entero está expectante ante el
inicio de estas conversaciones el
canciller ruso sérguei lávrov el
canciller de este país precisamente
conversó ante los medios de comunicación
rusos sobre estas mesas de diálogo dijo
que hay que tenerlas muy bien preparadas
porque son muchos los temas que tienen
que abordar
putin dijo que nunca se ha negado a una
reunión con el presidente es el inss que
lo único que él considera esencial es
que esas reuniones deben estar
preparadas ahora la situación es que hay
una crisis en ucrania el conflicto intra
ucraniano ha madurado durante tanto
tiempo a lo largo de todos estos años
que se ha acumulado una gran cantidad de
problemas es por eso que solo reunirnos
e intercambiar puntos de vista sobre lo
que piensas lo que pienso yo ahora sería
contraproducente es producto wood
contour production la más reciente
actualidad en torno a lo que está
pasando en ucrania después de ya más de
un meses de la invasión de rusia o desde
el inicio de esta operación militar
especial dependiendo del punto de vista
como usted lo quiera ver lo vamos a
analizar aquí en el debate de france 24
y tema importante para destacar esa mesa
de negociaciones que comenzará en
turquía podrá la diplomacia y el diálogo
poner fin a esta confrontación para
analizar este tema saludamos a florencia
tonelli ella es licenciada en relaciones
internacionales y también es magíster en
sociología política internacional ella
se encuentra en la bella ciudad de
buenos aires en argentina también está
con nosotros y van gatón él es académico
de relaciones internacionales experto en
geopolítica él es dominicano pero se
encuentra también en la bella ciudad de
madrid en españa ustedes nuestros
televidentes pueden participar en el
debate con sus comentarios y sus
preguntas lo pueden a través de las
redes sociales no se encuentran en
facebook en instagram en twitter estamos
como france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
nuestro numeral o nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
los comentarios y preguntas relacionadas
con este tema comienzo con florencia en
la ciudad de buenos aires en argentina
bienvenida a florencia bienvenida al
programa y comienzo preguntándole por
esas declaraciones del presidente yo
bailé en las repercusiones el alcance
que puede tener esas palabras que tiene
al mundo entero nervioso digámoslo así
bueno en primer lugar buenas tardes
santiago es un placer poder estar acá
qué difícil las palabras de biden y lo
que posiblemente
suceda yo creo que
vemos que la reacción de la casa blanca
es relativamente rápida tienen esta
necesidad de moderar la retórica como
bien mencionaste en tu resumen y
obviamente porque decir que es necesario
un cambio de régimen en rusia es
básicamente invitar a rusia a una nueva
escalada en el conflicto y obviamente
lleva a complicar mucho las cosas mucho
más de lo que ya están complicadas
me parece que no obstante
bailes no dice nada nuevo sí y esto
también lo vamos a ver reflejado en el
comunicado de la otan que creo que
también lo vamos a charlar en un rato
pero me parece que no dice nada nuevo en
el sentido de vamos a mantener la ayuda
a ucrania vamos a seguir impulsando los
valores democráticos y los valores
liberales en el mundo y liberal y en el
mundo no democrático y si de alguna
manera se escuda también dentro de esa
lógica que es muy estadounidense y que
es una lógica histórica histórica que es
la de alguna manera hacerlos los que
llevan la democracia y expanden la
democracia al mundo sur y me parece que
no no vamos a ver mucho más que eso en
ese sentido sí yo creo que putin no se
va a sentir amenazado realmente por la
frase que dijo hayden y que la casa
blanca se encargó de moderar
y van en la ciudad de madrid' su opinión
sobre estas declaraciones del presidente
joe biden que han molestado por supuesto
al kremlin en moscú
el presidente del aire
evidentemente tuvo un desliz que bueno
sus asesores han tratado de enmendar
porque evidentemente que este tipo de
declaraciones el fortalece aún más
a los diseñadores de política del
kremlin que viven que tiene muy claro
que desde hace un buen tiempo que los
demócratas no han tenido una actitud muy
halagüeña con la administración y
con con el gobierno de putin de hecho
cuando vemos el escenario actual
y como lo decía el presidente en francés
el manual macro
lo que se necesita es echar menos leña
al fuego es evidente que la situación de
ucrania está marcando una nueva era de
las relaciones internacionales sería
como una especie de gran transición
histórica
geopolítica y que hay que tener mucho
cuidado en ese tipo de declaraciones y
más procediendo del presidente de la
digamos de la primera potencia del mundo
claro
florencia estábamos viendo y ya ustedes
comentaron lo que significan estas
palabras del presidente de byd en rusia
tradicionalmente es un país que responde
no solamente a través de los medios de
comunicación a través de sus portavoces
sino que no inmediatamente tiempo
después rusia puede
[Música]
y darle a conocer al mundo sus
discrepancias o que este tipo de
comentarios no le cayó muy bien qué
podemos esperar entonces de parte del
kremlin de putin de rusia en general en
respuesta a este tipo de comentarios que
por el momento simplemente ha tenido
como respuesta desde la desde los
portavoces y los cancilleres como
washington que se aparte de nuestros
asuntos internos
bueno en parte yo creo que esa es la
primera respuesta coherente
impulsar esta idea de que eeuu está
permanentemente intentando involucrarse
en los asuntos internos de rusia y de
otros países porque no obligamos esto y
de alguna forma fomenta la narrativa
rusa me parece que vamos a ver muy
probablemente en los representantes de
rusia en los distintos organismos
internacionales se van a hacer con el
uso de esta frase desafortunada de
bailén para justificar su continuo
accionar en ucrania y él también porque
y también porque eeuu es realmente
supuestamente según ellos
una potencia de las cuales ellos tienen
que cuidarse y sigue siendo una potencia
que amenaza a la seguridad de rusia y
justifica el accionar de rusia en
ucrania me parece que esta va a ser el
principal uso que se le va a dar a esa
frase y la principal respuesta que va a
permitir dar rusia que le va claro le va
a permitir dar a rusia en la utilización
de esa frase claro y desde el kremlin
pueden y comenzar a hacer todo tipo de
advertencias a nivel internacional
porque rusia tiene que mantener a raya
gobiernos extranjeros que estén opinando
involucrándose en sus asuntos internos
es completamente esperable no solo de
rusia sino de cualquier país pero
entonces y banesto le puede dar digamos
impulso a este discurso que ha
llevado a cabo el kremlin a lo largo de
los últimos meses para justificar su
operación militar como ellos la llaman
en ucrania para justificar muchas de sus
acciones a nivel internacional un
discurso que han venido construyendo y
elaborando esta supuesta amenaza a nivel
internacional hacia rusia y de esa
necesidad del kremlin de ser tenido en
cuenta en la toma de decisiones
internacionales esto les da un impulso
como lo que usted
no solamente le da un impulso sino que
nuevamente viene a reafirmar lo que
planteó el gran diseñador de la doctrina
truman diplomático estadounidense
llamado george keenan quien hablaba de
de ese temor ruso de todo lo que podría
proceder después y como los rusos
mantienen una actitud de cautela porque
evidentemente en su historia en la cual
siempre han estado muy anclados les
demuestra que de que siempre han sido
invadidos y que siempre han intentado de
una manera u otra
acceder a su gran espacio es como
el el tener ese ese gran dilema de un
país tan grande con 17 millones de
kilómetros cuadrados
con apenas 140 millones de personas
todos los politólogos siempre indican
que los temores que tienen y tim hoy son
los mismos que tuvo en su momento pero y
grande que tuvo catalina la grande y que
ha sido y que han sido los temores que
han tenido todos los mandatarios muchos
como una especie de determinismo
geográfico con una gran cantidad de
recursos que hace que los rusos siempre
teman de todo lo que provenga de fuera
si es un temor transversal a lo largo de
la historia rusa un temor transversal no
solo para quienes han gobernado el país
para los áreas para los soviéticos y
para los presidentes sino también para
la misma población rusa yo sienten que
el mundo en cierta forma
va a venir a reclamar algo allí en el
territorio ruso ivan continuó con usted
allí en madrid para hacer la ronda a la
inversa este tipo de respuestas estas
discrepancias entre washington en moscú
están comenzando a deteriorar las
relaciones entre los dos países
se descarta entonces de pronto avances a
nivel diplomático entre los dos países
para empezar a bajar un poco los ánimos
en torno a la crisis internacional que
ha desatado esta invasión a ucrania
porque es que además estamos hablando de
dos potencias nucleares que están
empezando a tener discrepancias a nivel
del discurso con estas declaraciones
es preocupante porque evidentemente
los y los que conocen cómo se maneja el
gran tablero del ajedrez de la política
mundial sabe que existe en reyes y que
también hay peones y que en este caso
ucrania si bien es un país soberano va a
depender de lo que determinen los rusos
y lo que determinen lo en washington y
evidentemente que a la actitud de parte
de washington no es la de buscar una
salida negociada al conflicto porque
vimos las negociaciones que se
estuvieron llevando a cabo entre el en
seguéi lávrov el bling en a los fines de
de poder apaciguar los ánimos y no
llegar a un enfrentamiento bélico entre
rusia y ucrania pero me parece que desde
washington no hay una proclividad a que
se pueda hacer una negociación que
permite satisfacer ambas partes cuando
vimos al presidente saleh antes que
decir que ellos no quieren ingresar a la
otan los principales analistas de estos
temas dicen que es tarde o temprano esto
iba a suceder porque no se llevó esto a
una mesa de negociaciones y evitar
diplomáticamente una guerra está
marcando un antes y un después en las
relaciones internacionales
florencia no sé si usted está de acuerdo
por una de las grandes perjudicadas a
nivel internacional de este conflicto
esta invasión o guerra como se le quiera
llamar dependiendo del punto de vista
que uno lo mire ha sido la diplomacia
precisamente se agotó muy rápido en
muchísimas instancias y por eso estamos
en el escenario que en él
se puede reconstruir esto a nivel
diplomático y lo pregunto porque estamos
a punto de comenzar una mesa de diálogo
en estambul entre ucrania y rusia si hay
espacio para democracia
ya dada la instancia en la que estamos
de este conflicto
en primer lugar yo coincido plenamente
con lo que marcaba iván y sumado al
análisis que hace iván que me parece
extremadamente pertinente yo insisto y
lo he dicho varias veces en otros medios
también que la única salida es la salida
vía por la vía diplomática y por la vía
de negociación me parece que en esa mesa
no debe estar eeuu por lo menos no en
las mesas en las que se discutan
se discuta la paz si se quiere entre
ucrania y rusia porque eeuu
lamentablemente y como lo marca y van lo
único que ha hecho ha sido en pantanal
toda la cuestión diplomática desde las
negociaciones previas a la invasión de
rusia y de ucrania por parte de rusia
para ser más clara vemos que más allá de
que haya habido negociaciones entre
ladrón y entre blinken
posterior a esas negociaciones en las
redes sociales publicaban posibles
fechas de invasión mencionaban que rusia
era un estado agresor verificaban la
imagen de la imagen de putin como
presidente
no hay del mismo lo ha llamado en su
propio discurso de asunción un asesino
entonces la narrativa estadounidense
dentro de este conflicto
en mi opinión no ha hecho más que
empantana la cuestión diplomática y yo
creo que la salida si bien la única
salida es a través de la vía diplomática
eeuu no tendría que estar en la mesa de
negociaciones por lo menos no en las
primeras por lo menos en esa mesa que va
a comenzar en estambul en turquía en las
próximas horas o en los próximos días
dentro de este marco diplomático haga la
aclaración porque deje la palabra que no
era diplomático el presidente selenski
ha dicho que por lo menos desde el lado
ucraniano están listos para negociar esa
neutralidad y el estatus de neutralidad
nuclear y el estatus de neutralidad para
ucrania como un primer paso para avanzar
en esas conversaciones florencia qué
significa este estatus de neutralidad
qué repercusiones puede traer esto y
cómo deja entonces el conflicto que
llevamos hasta ahora un mes en donde
rusia ha ganado terreno sobre todo en el
este
bueno básicamente y para decirlo de
manera resumida si se quiere significa
una victoria para rusia no sé si la
victoria que a rusia esperaba pero es
una victoria para rusia significa que
ucrania no va a intentar ingresar en la
otan ni ahora ni nunca de hecho mientras
tenga la región del donbass fuera de su
control territorial no puede pedir
ingresar a la otan porque ese es uno de
los requisitos debe tener total control
de su territorio y por otro lado también
quizás perjudique las relaciones o un
intento de ingreso a la unión europea
esto quizás tenga otras complicaciones y
otras complejidades que tendríamos que
ver en el futuro en el día a día pero me
parece que en principio esto implicaría
obviamente no necesariamente un nuevo
acercamiento hacia rusia sino
precisamente como lo dice la palabra una
neutralidad en torno a lo que es
occidente y rusia
iván cuál es su opinión sobre este
estatus de neutralidad lograría entonces
moscú que ucrania se convierta en ese
estado bisagra entre la unión europea y
rusia- sea un estado digamos colchón que
se pare muy bien y divida muy bien a
estos dos bandos digámoslo así en europa
pero entonces qué futuro le puede
esperar a ucrania en el marco de esta
neutralidad y en sus relaciones con
bruselas y con moscú
pero la historia de la humanidad le ha
demostrado que siempre los imperios han
tenido sus esferas de influencia
y en el caso
que nos atañe
los principales diseñadores de políticas
de eeuu que la década de los 70 como
henry kissinger el mismos vídeo
brzezinski
que fue un demócrata
halcón
plantearon
ucrania debería tener una
una finlandés acción como se llama los
posmodernos son los que piensan que no
existen las esferas de influencia de los
imperios y yo creo que ahí existe una
total negación de esto a pesar de todo
el mundo siempre ha tenido una visión
muy joven jana es el del hombre como un
lobo para el hombre la guerra como
partera de la historia y sabemos que no
es por democracia ni por derechos
humanos que se hacen guerras sino por
intereses y que evidentemente
en el siglo 20 a partir de ese idealismo
que se trató de imponer las relaciones
internacionales se quiso dejar de lado
estos elementos que marcan como pauta la
historia de los pueblos y es que estar
cerca de un gran imperio siempre es un
gran inconveniente solamente hay que
preguntarle a los polacos cuando los
prusianos y los alemanes luego junto con
los rusos se repartían el territorio
polaco
ya vamos a hablar de esa propuesta de
moscú tengo otra pregunta para hacerle
evans
sobre el papel que ha tenido la onu la
onu está también tratando de mediar en
estas conversaciones para lograr un alto
el fuego como analiza usted el papel que
ha tenido la organización de naciones
unidas en este conflicto muchos la han
criticado por estar ausente por dejarle
esto en manos a la unión europea eeuu y
rusia y no ponerse del lado de los
ucranianos que son los que crearon en la
mitad del fuego cruzado
y de los combates entre el ejército ruso
y el ejército ucraniano
bueno es que la organización de naciones
unidas no se le puede exigir más de lo
que puede dar cuando vemos la alta
cuando vemos el póster cuando vemos la
carta de san francisco y cinco miembros
del consejo de seguridad con derecho al
reto es una clara indicación
de que ese organismo iba a ser regido
por los que tienen el poder y en las
guerras se ha demostrado y ya tenemos
guerras anteriores como por el caso de
yugoslavia tenemos el caso de
de irak
y tenemos el caso actual de yemen
obtuvimos el caso en el pongo de la
guerra del coltán
y casi siempre naciones unidas su
secretario general se ve un poco atado
de manos porque los miembros del consejo
de seguridad son los que determinan
florencia iba mencionaba en estos países
que han sido divididos o repartidos en
su momento entre el mundo occidental e
iba mencionaba el caso de polonia entre
los prusianos o alemanes posteriormente
y los soviéticos el presidente putin ha
dicho que una de las propuestas puede
ser dividir ucrania ellos ya han ganado
mucho territorio en el este el donbass
prácticamente pues lo han reconocido ya
como una república independiente pero
fácilmente lo podrían anexar como lo
hicieron con con crimea en el 2014 esto
nos recuerda escenarios similares del
pasado como corea como vietnam como la
misma finlandia cuando la invadieron los
soviéticos que le tocó ceder todo el
istmo de karelia para poder
quitarse digamos de encima los militares
rusos y poder ser un país independiente
y poder ya comenzar una vida como una
república este escenario es viable puede
ser un escenario factible para ucrania
si estamos hablando también de un
estatus de neutralidad
a mí me parece que no creo que en la
palabra recordar no sirve justamente por
ese mismo motivo no recordar cuáles
fueron las instancias en las que se
dieron esos sucesos estamos hablando de
un momento en la historia en la que la
política internacional y el derecho
internacional no tenían la fortaleza que
tiene hoy más allá de que también vemos
que el derecho internacional hoy tiene
sus falencias
no obstante lo que es el respeto hacia
la integridad territorial como el
principio del derecho internacional es
generalmente uno de los principios que
más se respetan en este sentido una
salida negociada entre rusia y ucrania
no creo que se dé la anexión de los
obras de lugansk y de donges que me
parece que ese es uno de los puntos
fuertes en los que ucrania puede pedir
que rusia respete el derecho
internacional porque ucrania está
cediendo su posibilidad de entrar a la
otan está cediendo
su
intención es si se quiere de acercarse
mucho más occidente y dejar detrás la
relación con con rusia entonces creo que
en ese sentido rusia ti no provocaran ya
tiene un punto fuerte para negociar y
decir necesito que este punto en
particular que es la integridad
territorial de este estado los respetes
es la única vía para la paz
iván que piensa usted de estas palabras
de florencia la es la carta de ucrania
para poder negociar exigir el respeto a
su integridad territorial pero quien
convence a los rusos ya de integridad
territorial hablábamos en el 2014 y
ucrania le tocó ver como le quitaban la
península de crimea y cómo pasaba a ser
una república dentro de la federación de
rusia lo mismo le pasó a georgia con
osetia y con la afasia quien convence a
los rusos de estos valores del derecho
internacional y de la integridad
territorial
cuando ya ellos han fomentado el
separatismo en el este de ucrania
yo creo que para los rusos
ucrania es como una parte esencial para
su seguridad y las señales como usted
decía la vinieron dando con el caso de
chechenia también con el mismo caso de
asia y josep ya y también tomar en
consideración que los rusos estudiaron
en siria donde tienen una base militar
es decir todo lo que es para los rusos
sea importante que o estratégicamente
hablando
no creo que vayan a tomar en
consideración el derecho internacional
sería lo mejor en una visión kantiana
idealista pero lo que nos demuestra
rusia en el devenir del tiempo es que
pasó pesares a un ser rojo como stalin
a un área digamos más por más posmoderno
como sería el caso de vladimir putin
y tal parece que este país siempre tiene
que estar gobernado por hombres fuertes
que están allí en el kremlin gobernando
con un poco de mano dura si lo dice la
historia de rusia florencia también
destacado esta semana en los últimos
días en torno a la actualidad ucraniana
hay otras palabras del presidente se le
han escrito y quiero citar para
dimensionar el alcance de lo que tiene y
el presidente acusó a occidente de falta
de coraje para apoyar a ucrania en la
defensa de su país frente a rusia está
el mundo occidental viendo que esta
guerra se está tomando más de lo
esperado está empezando a desacelerar
todo ese impulso ese movimiento que hubo
a nivel internacional que es el esquí se
mostró como un héroe nacional un nuevo
ídolo a nivel internacional y ahora el
mundo occidental ya lo está dejando
pasar un poco y que los ucranianos ya se
vayan a su suerte y se defiendan de los
rusos como puedan como lo ve usted
me parece que esa ha sido la postura de
occidente desde incluso antes de la
invasión de rusia no necesariamente en
hacer no no explicitada a que voy con
esto
eeuu la otan la unión europea' todos
mostraron su apoyo a selenski y el
cráneo obviamente con sus intenciones de
ingresar al otan con sus intenciones de
ingresar a la unión europea pero también
fomentaron un discurso que obviamente
molestó en el kremlin molesto a putin y
que obviamente fomentó
la invasión por parte de rusia y ucrania
y una vez que invade el realmente la
situación se complejiza la otan sabe que
no puede intervenir militarmente en
ucrania porque eso implicaría
inevitablemente escalar el conflicto a
lo que sí sería una tercera guerra
mundial
eeuu tiene que manejar con mucho cuidado
su discurso cosa que yo creo que no está
haciendo
y en este proceso
ocurre lo que nosotros en argentina
decimos es excelencia y se come el verso
es decir
cree en las palabras de la otan cree en
las palabras de la unión europea cree en
las palabras de eeuu lo hace quizás
ingenuamente o ciegamente y ahora vemos
que occidente tiene bastante facilidad
para otorgar ayuda humanitaria sí sin
duda pero también para soltarle la mano
porque sabe que complejizar el conflicto
más allá de la frontera de ucrania
implicaría
básicamente la destrucción de gran parte
de la humanidad
iván su opinión sobre este tema
bueno
asistimos a una situación muy
muy particular y es alentar a que un
pueblo pelé pero con la gran diferencia
de que no estamos hablando de una
versión bíblica del siglo 21 de un david
y goliat aquí evidentemente el pueblo
ucraniano
no podrás vencer al ejército ruso maxim
o puede hacerle frente y detenerlo pero
mientras tanto están poniendo los
cadáveres de los muertos están
sacrificando su país ante una guerra que
ya el propio presidente bailén había
pronunciado que eeuu en caso de que
putin invadiera ucrania como craneano
era miembro del de la otan no iba a
intervenir y desde los tiempos de asia
dios sería lo de lo que sucedió en
georgia occidente dio demostraciones de
debilidad o relación a rusia entonces
esas demostraciones de debilidad
ucrania a merced de rusia se creo que de
una manera u otra ponen en entredicho
el interés de occidente para ayudar a
ucrania
me quedan ya pocos minutos para terminar
el programa quiero cerrar también con
otro hecho destacado a lo largo de los
últimos días y es el anuncio hecho por
el diario ruso nóvaya gazeta de dejar de
operar
hasta tanto la invasión a rusia o esta
operación militar como quieran llamarla
finalice esto es otro golpe a la
libertad de expresión ya la
necesidad de los rusos de informarse
libremente es otro golpe a la ha sido
censurado este medio prácticamente así
lo han dicho varios medios occidentales
y van en su opinión sobre esta
operación desde el kremlin que ha
coartado un poco la libertad de
expresión allí para los rusos ha
expulsado a periodistas extranjeros ha
cerrado los burós de medios como por
ejemplo deutsche welle de alemania y
ahora pues uno de los pocos diarios
independientes deja de operar
no es algo que debamos sorprendernos
sobre todo hay que tomar en
consideración que la nomenclatura
política que acompaña a putin viene de
la antigua unión de repúblicas
socialistas soviéticas
para ellos es algo digamos común y
corriente es un asunto que también el
occidente no tomó en consideración y es
que hasta los demócratas como helsing
venían de las estructuras de la unión de
repúblicas socialistas soviéticas es
decir que esa
esa libertad a la prensa no es algo que
se puede esperar en rusia sería como
desconocer un poco sus contextos
históricos claro es otro capítulo de la
guerra mediática si lo han calificado
varios medios occidentales
florencia su opinión sobre esto y le
añado ese anuncio también hecho por el
gobierno ruso de modificar un poco los
programas de estudio en el país para
enseñarle a los jóvenes rusos que
ucrania nunca fue un país independiente
y que siempre ha sido un país un estado
que ha estado ligado a la historia rusa
y que siempre ha tenido una conexión
histórica con moscú que es cierto pero
hay algo que hay que decir es que desde
la década del 90 y ucrania es un estado
independiente
sí totalmente
primero y principal la cuestión
mediática estamos viendo que lo que
rusia intenta hacer es de alguna manera
contrarrestar
todo el aparato mediático de occidente y
todos los ataques mediáticos y la
narrativa mediática que se crea y que
sirve en función de dignificar a
vladimir putin no al pueblo ruso en sí
sino a vladimir putin como presidente y
en general quizás aislados y actores que
ayudan a putin vemos que china también
entra dentro de esta narrativa pero de
manera más moderada de manera más
relajada
no debería sorprender el accionar de
rusia como bien turban es parte de su
historia y en muchos sentidos no hay una
tradición de respeto hacia los derechos
humanos en rusia con respecto a la
segunda pregunta que me agregaste de
santiago
es lo que vos mencionás hay una relación
histórica entre rusia y ucrania pero
también hay que ver que ucrania tiene su
propia identidad y siempre ha tenido su
propia identidad y siempre este ha sido
un punto fundamental en lo que es la
presentación de ucrania hacia el resto
del mundo ya fuese comunista o
independiente a partir de 1991 o previo
incluso a su incorporación en la unión
soviética en el año 1922 si esto era el
factor fundamental me parece de ucrania
para establecerse y para presentarse y
auto percibirse dentro del sistema
internacional iván florencia les
agradezco que hayan actualizado con
nosotros y analizado estos hechos
destacados del avance que tiene esta
invasión de rusia al territorio
ucraniano o la guerra en ucrania a
ustedes muchas gracias por haber estado
con nosotros en esta edición del debate
y sigan viendo france24
[Música]